you've seen him in Mad Max fury road now
you got to play him in overwatch doneger
Dwyer joined by mr. Chris waters for the
latest overwatch hero guide let's talk
about Road hull road hog the big dog man
that is he's the biggest dude right he
seems to be he's probably one of the
more intimidating heroes on the on the
on the battlefield I always feel like I
run away when I see him coming he draws
a lot of attention and he has that giant
scrap gun with two big barrels that you
definitely don't want to get close to
it's got two fire modes basically right
you sort of got your short blast and
then the kind of a mid-range shot as
well
mid-range I think is maybe even
exaggerating short blast is someone
who's right next to you you know you
could reach out and touch him the
mid-range blast is there just a little
further away you know you're not
engaging people that are really far away
you can kind of Harry them and like
throw chips in their face but you're not
doing any real damage unless you're in
pretty close I feel like the only reason
he has two firing modes is because he
has the chain hook which is one of his
abilities that basically allows you to
drag somebody like within like kissing
distance basically and this is the key
to playing road hog well is working that
hook because what that hook does aside
from the obvious of yanking someone real
close so you can blast their face off it
disrupts the other team it freaks them
out when they see you because they know
even if they're not close to you they
could be any second because you could
throw that hook out bring them in and
then you've caused a lot of trouble for
them who are the folks you think you
should aim that hook - because obviously
roadog he's always in the sort of front
of the battle he's always surrounded by
lots of people in there causing trouble
I mean you could really point it at
anyone should you be pointing it at
tanks are they - you know dangerous
should you be aiming it at the sky at
Farah who do you think you should be
grabbing in this oh man if you can drag
fire down out of this guy do it it's so
satisfying but yeah I do I deal you're
bringing in the offensive support you
know the support characters the
defensive characters who you can pop in
one shot who for whom the hook spells
death you know you bring in a Reinhardt
you're gonna have a lot of trouble but
bringing in a Reinhardt when you've got
some support and when the Reinhardt is
being particularly pernicious on the
point he can be real tough solo because
he's got a huge swinging arc on that
hammer if his healers are great pull in
as in yata pull in a mercy pull in a
friggin lucio and oh baby shut him down
there's a great little combo with road
hog and widow-makers infrared as well
that you can basically use that to sort
of almost be a little stealthy road hog
and grab somebody around the corner when
they least expect it watching them and
throwing the hook out when you see that
silhouette just about to come around the
corner is the rudest surprise but it
feels so good the chain hook actually
has a pretty quick cooldown so you know
you're not using it every other shot but
you can use it more than you think you
can and you really should be using it
because even if you miss it's still that
the just that rattle the chain out there
really messes with their minds for sure
and of course if you haven't been
working at if you if you missed those
shots and you're taking some damage can
also take a little breather with Rogoff
oh he's got his own little health pack
did he just like attaches to his gas Mac
and sucks on down which is such a great
animation it gives you 300 health right
away and this is something ideally you
want to duck behind a corner you want to
get out of the line of fire to use but
if you're in a tight spot suck that down
while you're being shot or whatever and
it might just buy you enough time to
stay alive as you can imagine Road hogs
also got a pretty meaty alt in whole hog
Tommy Bennett Chris he just starts
cranking on that scrap gun and bullets
start flying everywhere in front of you
in a broad spread and though they do
damage their primary impulse is to shove
I mean they push people back they push
you off a point they push you back into
a choke point this is a great crowd
control ultimate something that you know
when the enemy team is pushing that last
point when you're counting down if you
can get out and start cranking you are
going to buy your team some serious time
to maybe give you the edge
I mean Road hogs are really good sort of
a offensive tank for hassling people in
a weird way and they're also some
cautionary tales for him though people
he should stay away from I mean we've
all seen the gif of him pulling a nice
ulting Diva mech straight towards in but
there's also characters like neigh which
caused him a lot of problem Oh May I was
playing a tank today and made just
continues to give tanks no end of
problems she can freeze them especially
roadog has his big dome right on top
he's a real magnet for a headshot yeah
so you want to get distance on May even
pulling her in can be tricky because she
can icicle up real quick and then once
she pops out she's gonna go ahead and
freeze you down so you want to you know
keep her at a distance awesome that's
road hog overwatch is very own war Boy
make sure you check him out I'm be sure
to check out all of our other overwatch
hero guides right here on gang spot coms
YouTube channel and on gang spot comm